the total mechanical energy ease of mech
is defined as the sum of the kinetic
energy and the potential energy so the
sum of K plus u where u is the potential
energy function associated with the
conservative force with an appropriate
choice of zero point if there are
multiple conservative forces acting on
the system then you will be the sum of
individual potential energy functions
for each conservative force with an
appropriate choice of zero point for
each individual function we've also seen
that the change in the kinetic energy
plus the change in the potential energy
is equal to the change in the total
mechanical energy and that's just
basically the derivative of the equation
that I wrote above and this change in
the total mechanical energy will be zero
for conservative forces in addition
we've seen that the change in potential
energy is related to the conservative
work done in the system so that W sub C
the conservative work done is equal to
the negative of the change in the
potential energy but we also know that
the total work done includes both
conservative and non-conservative forces
so the total work done is equal to the
sum of W sub C the conservative work
done plus the non conservative work done
and that that total work is equal to the
change in kinetic energy now I can
rewrite that equation by rewriting the
conservative work in terms of the
potential energy so I could write this
now as the non conservative work minus
the change in the potential and
G is equal to the change the kinetic
energy this is again just a restatement
of the work kinetic energy theorem now
by rearranging this equation this means
that the non conservative work is equal
to Delta K the change in kinetic energy
plus Delta U the change in potential
energy but that's equal to the change in
the total mechanical energy so the non
conservative work is equal to the change
in the total mechanical energy this is a
sufficiently important result that I'm
gonna write it by itself in a box that's
so the non conservative work is equal to
the change in the total mechanical
energy so what we've shown here is that
the result of any non conservative work
on the system is to change the total
mechanical energy of the system now if
there is no non conservative work if the
forces acting on the system are all
conservative then the total mechanical
energy remains unchanged Delta e mech is
zero and we say that the total
mechanical energy is conserved now if
there is a non conservative force it
turns out that in most cases the work
done by a non conservative force is
negative resulting in a negative change
in the total mechanical energy in other
words and in the removal of total
mechanical energy from the system its
lost from the system now we've been
talking here only about mechanical
energy which we've defined as the sum of
kinetic energy and potential energy but
one can also talk about non mechanical
energy the most common example of which
is loosely referred to as heat as an
example in the case of friction which is
a non conservative force we know that
the act
friction generates heat what's happening
is that the non-conservative work done
by friction is negative and therefore is
reducing the mechanical energy the total
mechanical energy according to this
expression but where does that energy go
we said that it's removed from the
system in terms of mechanical energy
that's true but we can think of it as at
the same time causing an increase in the
non mechanical energy or the heat energy
of the system so if one were to keep
track of both mechanical and non
mechanical energy then that turns out
that the total energy mechanical and non
mechanical the total energy of the
system is conserved even if non
conservative forces are acting however
it's difficult to recover the non
mechanical energy and change it back
into mechanical energy these non
conservative processes are not
reversible this is a complicated topic
and it's the province of more advanced
courses in thermodynamics or statistical
mechanics which you may encounter later
in this course we will confine our
attention to mechanical energy with the
sum of kinetic energy and potential
energy and we'll treat non conservative
force as removing or adding mechanical
energy to the system